sanctify them through thy truth
thy word is truth
but what is sanctification
how is it manifested
the word inspired sabbath february 26 at
2 o'clock p.m eastern standard time for
a q a with elder randy skeet on
sanctification
other special guests include lawrence
awa
courtney fedlin and queen myers
questions from the live audience will
also be taken even if not directly
related to the topic
this meeting will be hosted on zoom and
live streamed to denisha mccurchion's
youtube channel personal on the word
inspired facebook pages and twitter and
twitch profiles at the word inspired
links are in the description of this
video feel free to like share and
subscribe we hope to see you there and
welcome your prayers and support as we
finish the work of the gospel
this is the word inspired taking god's
word to all the world
thank you and god bless
all right everyone let us have a word of
prayer
dear lord we thank you for this
opportunity to just praise your name on
this your sabbath day and we thank you
for giving us this opportunity to have a
discussion on sanctification
and we know this is your will for us so
please guide and direct the proceedings
of this program acts in a special way
that you would anoint your man's servant
elder randy skeet put your words in his
mouth fill him with your holy spirit and
even allow him to answer the questions
effectively and efficiently i pray that
we would all leave with a closer walk
with you and be drawn to your word we
thank you for hearing and answering this
prayer in jesus name amen
now
before we proceed
elder skeet i know i did not ask you to
do this before but i'm thinking about
the war that is happening between russia
and ukraine i'm thinking about the many
persons that are affected and the hearts
that are breaking
and you know just the
how can i say the unsettlement that is
present in this world and elderski i'd
be grateful if you can say a special
prayer for those that are affected by
this war of course
thank you are we praying
our father in heaven we come into your
presence at your invitation
your god of mercy your god of peace
we are aware of what's happening in
ukraine
and there are people suffering even as
we pray
we ask you first of all forgive our sins
they god
for the sake of christ
and we ask you to extend mercy
it is the enemy who leads nations to
fight wars
to distract us from the work of the
gospel
you have people in ukraine their god
members of the household of faith
but beyond that
your word says he maketh his son to rise
on the evil and on the good and so
father we ask you as your children to be
merciful to what's happening in ukraine
be close to your people their father
wherever you will ease suffering prevent
tragedy but keep your hand of protection
upon your people we place that situation
in your hand but father help us to
remember as we pray for ukraine that
this is just a sign of the soon return
of your son so please god be merciful to
your people in ukraine i pray
as soon as possible father bring an end
to that conflict and wherever we are let
us be people of peace and harmony
in jesus name i pray amen
amen amen thank you so much
and let me
introduce you
properly well friends we are joined
today by a man of god that has traveled
the world that is on fire for our savior
and is attuned to the leading of the
holy spirit we have none other than
elder randy skeets who has trained for
the ministry at oakwood university and
the sda theological seminary at the end
of university and today he will be
answering the questions that we have on
sanctification and some open forum
questions that have been sent in now if
you also have a question and you're here
live on the zoom we will give you the
opportunity to unmute and also pose your
question
but in the meantime please pray
think and reflect
as elder randy skeet speaks please
welcome elder randy skeet
thank you dr denisha i'm grateful
i've said it before i'll say it again it
is a privilege for me to be a part of
this ministry it really is
and i asked god to tell me what to tell
his people so that the truth may open
eyes and the truth may set people free
who are currently bound and shackled in
error you know jesus prayed to the
father in john 17 verse 17
sanctify them through thy truth thy word
is truth error has no sanctify effect
whatsoever and our subject is
sanctification so may the lord put the
words in my mouth that the words i speak
may be the words of truth
and i'm ready for the first question
amen amen thank you all the skeet well
our next question is very
straightforward can you turn up your
volume denisha
oh can you hear me better now ah yes yes
that's much better okay awesome let me
pull this fight closer then
first question is what is sanctification
sanctification
is the process of growth in christ in ii
peter chapter 3 verse 18 the bible says
grow in grace and in the knowledge of
our lord and savior jesus christ notice
that word knowledge you grow in grace
what is required for that the knowledge
of the lord and our savior jesus christ
jesus saw the father sanctify them
through thy truth
thy word is true of sanctification is
the process whereby god uses the
spirit-filled word with our cooperation
to bring us closer and closer to his
ideal for us to remove any affection we
have from the world for the world and to
fill us the capacity with affection and
desires only for the things of heaven
to express it differently sanctification
is the process of bringing us into
perfect conformity with the law of god
or sanctification is total obedience to
the law of god or sanctification
is submission to the will of god and the
will of god is his law
now there's something called
justification that is an instant act
that christ performs
when we come to him in total surrender
recognizing we cannot save ourselves he
is our only hope like the publican in
luke 18 13 who said god be merciful to
me a sinner jesus said in verse 14 that
man went down to his house justified in
other words made right with god
but he has to continue in that state and
grow in that state this is the process
of sanctification and sanctification
is god's will for everyone first
thessalonians chapter 4 3 this is the
will of god
even your sanctification
amen amen you know i really like how you
juxtapose justification as well to
sanctification
justification is imputed righteousness
sanctification is important
righteousness
and that's what we get when we have that
longing that effort that we make to be
in line as you said with the law of god
so it is not just jesus bless covering
us but us working towards that standard
of religion that is set forth in the
word of god so no it does not happen in
a day it takes a lifetime
this is the the emphasis of christ
in john chapter 15 if you read john 15
from verse 4
of john chapter 15 jesus says abide in
me and i in you the word abide the greek
word is menno it means to stay or
continue or remain and that word abide
occurs about nine times from verse four
to verse ten on one occasion it's
translated continue in verse nine of
john 15 and so jesus is saying abide
remain continue stay with me this is the
process of sanctification it's the
process of abiding in christ remaining
and will remain through constant
obedience to the word of god
amen amen that's why once saved is not
always saved absolutely not absolutely
not we must continue continue to abide
in christ thank you all the skeet so we
are moving on to our next question
our next question is
in what ways
or in what way is sanctification
in the sanctuary i'll say it again in
what way or in what ways is
sanctification seen in the sanctuary
good question because the sanctuary is
the source of our understanding of the
gospel that's why god gave that entire
system to the israelites they had spent
generations in egypt they were spiritual
children spiritual infants and god had
to use a kindergarten approach with
little pictures to teach them what the
gospel was and so you know david said
thy way or god is in the sanctuary now
in the sanctuary system we have the our
court we have the inner court or the
holy place and we have the most holy
justification summarizes what goes on in
the outer court where the animal is
slain
the the animal is burnt on that altar
just sanctification occurs in the holy
place that's the word that uh summarizes
what happens in the holy place in the
holy place we have the table of shoe
bread we have the candelabra and we have
the alta vincents so we have the word of
god we have the light and we have
constant prayer which is we send our
prayers which are mingled with the
merits of christ's sacrifice represented
by the insults and that makes them
acceptable to god so sanctification
is dramatized in the activities that
continue
that are carried out in the holy place
but let me also say that on occasion the
bloodshed in the outer court which
represents justification is brought into
the holy place and sprinkle on the altar
so that sanctification is not the end of
justification and the beginning of
something different justification can be
seen as the beginning of sanctification
so you cannot split the two let me say
that again justification is the first
step in sanctification
so if you run a mile you must make a
first step or you can't go anywhere and
just justification is the first step
there is not a gap of time between
justification and sanctification that's
impossible because if there's a gap in
this catastrophe the moment a person is
justified
sanctification begins
and so in the holy place where the
candelabrum gives light the bread
represents the word of god and the
instance representing the merits of
christ's sacrifice we see
sanctification as symbolized
amen amen you know elders i really liked
that uh
i want to i don't want to say analogy
but the metaphor that you use in terms
of
justification being the first step of
signification it almost reminds me of
that eight round ladder in second peter
chapter one that's right moving from
faith all the way up to charity like we
have to take that first step and it's
progressive
it is progressive yes it is
amen
so now elder skeet i'm going to
transition and allow brother lawrence
awards to ask you the next two questions
and just to give us some insight on who
brother lauren sawa is he's all the way
from ghana and he
recently started a youtube channel
called happy sabbath family happy family
yes happy sabbath family
he uploads uh short videos about five
minutes giving us a synopsis of the
lesson study we can study them quarterly
effectively so brother alarence awua the
floor is yours
and thank you for joining us
okay
thank you sister denisha
and thank you eldar randiski
thank you
um
now that we have known what
sanctification
is don't ask this question why must we
be sanctified
why are you rest will be sanctified
very good question i could ask the
question why must we be justified
sanctification
god's god's standard for us
is the very character of jesus christ
and we have to grow and grow in that
towards that now
in first peter chapter two i believe is
verse two the bible says as newborn
babes desire the sincere milk of the
word
say that again
can you hear me
i think i've lost brother
a war think the name is
can you hear me my brother
i can see him here's just indonesia but
i lost my good brother
yes i think his internet probably froze
okay okay well i'll still answer the
question
justification is required as long as
you're alive because we're moving moving
moving always to the absolute ideal
which is the perfect representation of
the character of jesus christ you know
ellen white writes in a education page
18 paragraph four
godliness godlikeness is the goal to be
reached and a goal is reached after a
period of time where someone strives and
reaches and reaches and as you said
earlier ii peter chapter one a reading
from verse five
you know at your faith virtue and divert
your knowledge knowledge temperance and
temperance godliness to godliness you
know so that ladder you're moving moving
moving so you go from a baby to an
infant to a whatever pre-adolescent
adolescent adult whatever it is it's a
growth process and as long as you're
alive that growth is required because if
someone says i don't need to grow the
person is saying i'm good enough as i am
and satan loves people who are
spiritually comfortable we must keep
growing in grace that is what we're told
in ii peter 3 18 sanctification is that
process of growth the fact that you
justify does not mean you automatically
lose your temper you automatically lose
whatever has caused problems you as you
grow in grace these things fall off fall
off but the person growing is a
justified person walking in the path of
scientification sanctifications
absolutely necessary or it would not
have been included in the activities of
the holy place all three compartments
are required what happens in the other
court what happens in the holy place and
what happens in the most holy place
which is glorification and even in the
new world will grow and grow and grow
because no one can exhaust the character
of god
amen amen amen
i don't know if brother awu is back but
i really appreciate the intentionality
that you are emphasizing here
sometimes we feel that if we just pray
all of our sinful tendencies will go
away
but he expects us to be very intentional
about putting our sin that's right we
know we're addicted to our cell phones
we can't move our cell phones all around
all with us everywhere we go if we get
tempted when we see a certain person or
a certain thing on a tv show then we
should remove ourselves from that person
or stop watching that tv show and this
is what sanctification is about that
constant striving after the standard of
righteousness that's right that's right
paul told timothy fight the good fight
of faith first timothy 6 12 fight the
good fight of faith and that fight
continues and continues until this
mortal puts on immortality
all right elder skeet i think brother
awu is back all right so i'm going to
allow him to ask hello
there he is
can somebody hear me please
yes i can hear you my goodness
yes i can
hello
can you hear me
can somebody hear me please okay animate
your phone
i can hear him but he can't hear me
can you hear me
i can hear you my brother can you hear
me
i guess i'll put something in the chat
yeah he's not hearing us
yes so
uh i said we we can hear you
all right so
okay i'm not even typing correctly let
me just ask the next question for the
sake of time yes please yes
by what means are we sanctified so we
know why we have to be sanctified we
know what sanctification is
but how does sanctification happen
jesus makes the process and the the the
the tool or the instrument
very plain
in his prayer to his father john 17 17
he said sanctify them through thy truth
thy word
is truth it is the word of god the
spirit-filled word of god that is the
agent into sanctification in john
chapter 15 in verse 3 jesus told his
disciples now you're clean through the
word which i have spoken to you so we
have the word as the agent of
sanctification in john 17 17 we have the
word in john 15 verse 3. you read
ephesians 5 from verse 25 husbands love
your wives even as christ also loved the
church and gave himself for it that he
might sanctify and cleanse it with the
washing of water by the word and so we
have the word again in christ object
lessons page 100 paragraph one ella
white writes the scriptures are the
primary agency in the transformation of
character and so the agent of
sanctification is the spirit-filled word
of god the spirit applies that word as
we surrender in obedience that is how
sanctification takes place psalm 119
verse 11 thy word have i hid in my heart
that i might not sin against thee it is
the word
spirit-filled spirit applied that
affects the process of sanctification
remove the word and there's no
sanctification you may develop decency
but you will never be sanctified
um
we need the word of the lord and new
friends you know in preparation i was
reading elder bodrow's uh sanctification
and he wrote that a lot of persons claim
to have the holy spirit or claim to have
the spirit and say because i have the
spirit i'm sanctified but then he said
but wait a second how does the whole
what what is the work of the holy spirit
jesus sent us the holy spirit to lead us
into truth and if john 17 17 says
sanctify them through thy truth thy word
is truth so we know
the word of god and we know that jesus
is the way the truth and the life as
john 14 6
so it is by applying this truth to our
lives that we are sanctified and note
god is gracious he doesn't give us all
the truth that we need to know at one
time but bit by bit he will reveal more
light and more light and more light
until we are fully transformed let me
also say this
obedience
there's no sanctification without
obedience and the obedience god requires
is that which is empowered by the spirit
of god and comes from the heart of the
person without obedience there is no
sanctification because ultimately
sanctification removes us further and
further from the conditions of the flesh
from the sins and that is then through
the obedience to god's word without
obedience there is no sanctification
which means the ultimate proof of
sanctification going on in a person's
life the ultimate proof of conversion is
plain and simple obedience to the word
of god
amen amen obedience
second samuel chapter 15 verse 22 to
obey is better than saying sacrifice
that's right first time you're 15 22.
yes yes samuel
harkin and the fat of rams
that's right
all right well elder skeet i see brother
lawrence is back so i'm going to allow
him to ask the last question okay
hello
yes i'm sorry about this i lost
connection no problem
okay well my question is
by what means are we sanctified
oh we just answered that
by the word of god jesus said in john 17
17 sanctify them through thy truth
thy word is truth it is the primary
agent in sanctification christ object
lessons page 100 paragraph one the
scriptures are the primary agency in the
transformation of character and that's
what sanctification is we must also pray
to be sanctified but in the work of
salvation god requires the cooperation
of man and so sanctification is the
process that is done in us by divine
power with human cooperation and that
power is lodged in the spirit-filled
word of god
so how how do we know we are sanctified
pastors obedience obedience plain and
simple obedience ongoing obedience an
increasing desire to cook uh to
cooperate with the will of god that is
the evidence of sanctification a
decreasing interest in the things of the
world that is evidence of sanctification
a willingness to cooperate and be one
with our father brother and sister to
remove division of disunity that is
evidence of sanctification
it is god who's the ultimate judge yes
but fellow believers should see evidence
of sanctification and the chief evidence
is
increasing obedience to thus saith the
lord and the greatest expression of thus
said the lord is found in the ten
commandments of god which are the whole
duty of man and by the way the whole
duty of angels
well um thank you pastor but
what do you have to say about first
thessalonians chapter 4 verse 3 and 4
do humans have roles to play in the
process of
sanctification because it says that for
this is the will of god
that you abstain from sexual immorality
that each of that each of you know how
to possess his own vessel of
scientification and hannah so doesn't
mean that do humans have
roles to play in the process of
scientification yes
we don't sanctify ourselves our role is
cooperation with what god is doing and i
see my brother is frozen again perhaps
his internet went down again but i'll
continue to answer our role is
cooperation with god we see that from
genesis of revelation
hello i can hear can you hear me brother
okay he has gone down again i hope the
rest can hear john 3 16 for god so loved
the world that he gave his only begotten
son but listen to the rest that
whosoever believeth in him there must be
a part we play what we play does not
sanctify us what we pray let's not
know continually we want to be
sanctified
matthew 11 28 come on to me only that
labor and i have elite we have to come
it's the spirit that convicts us to go
but we have to come isaiah 45 22 look
unto me and be save all the ends of the
world so yes there is a rule we play but
the discrete act of sanctification and
justification is the work of christ but
we by our correct cooperation we place
ourselves in a position where christ can
do what he wants to do when god told
abraham to sacrifice isaac in genesis 22
abraham did everything he had to do he
rose early took two servants woke up
isaac got the word took the knife took
the fire started walking identified the
place then god said now i know that the
affair is god because abraham by his
actions demonstrated
his cooperation with god there is
something we must do but the actual work
of cleansing is the work of god because
it's the blood of christ not my blood
but i must let god know i want to be
sanctified i must let god know i desire
this with all my heart and soul i must
take job's attitude not of jacob i will
not let you go except he sanctify me
this must be my attitude salvation
results from a cooperation between
divine and human but the actual saving
is done by the divine power the actual
sanctifying is done by a divine power i
cannot sanctify myself that's why i need
god but i can let god know i want to be
sanctified
by cooperating with him because it is
not forced on a person
nothing god does is forced when it comes
to salvation
amen god gives us the freedom of choice
amen thank you all the skeet for
answering that question
we lost the brother again i'm sorry i
know but thank god he was able to ask
those three questions all right okay
we have a question from our audience i
believe this is pastor reuben o'forey
okay he writes please is there any
connection between the holy spirit and
sanctification
absolutely
of course there is remove the holy
spirit and there's no sanctification
because the power of the word is the
spiral of the spirit in the word jesus
said in john 6 66 verse 63 it is the
spirit that quickeneth the flesh
prophetess nothing the words that i
speak unto you they are spirit and they
are life it is the spirit-filled word
that carries out the process of
sanctification remove the spirit and the
merits of christ's sacrifice cannot be
activated in the life of the believer it
is the spirit that applies the merits of
christ's sacrifice yes the holy spirit
is absolutely essential he represents
that divine power the spirit in the word
the spirit-filled word is what does that
job with our cooperation you cannot
remove the spirit romans chapter 8 tells
us in verse 9 if any man have not the
spirit of christ he's none of his romans
8 14 for as many as are led by the
spirit of god they are the sons of god
romans 8 16 for the spirit itself
beareth witness with our spirit that we
are the children of god you cannot
remove the spirit from any aspect of
salvation
amen amen in fact it's the spirit that
leads us to truth which sings it is the
spirit that leads us the truth yes
amen amen so pastor forrey i pray your
question was answered
and elder skeet thank you so much for
discussing these questions or discussing
these topics of sanctification
we are now going to be moving on to our
open forum questions that have been
submitted
i have one here from
elder wedebergen he wants to know
well this is this question in exodus 24
verses 9 through 11 we see that moses
aaron nadab and aby who and 70 elders of
israel saw god they ate and they're and
they drank
but in exodus 33 verse 20
jesus declares to moses thou canst not
see my face
there shall no man see me and live
how do we reconcile these passages
the bible does not contradict itself
because it has one author that's the
holy spirit and he is the spirit of
truth and truth does not have
contradictions
god god told moses it was christ who
told moses there shall no man see my
face and live moses never saw the face
of god
and he's the closest a human being has
come to god god said i will speak to
prophets and dreams but i'll speak to
moses face to face the expression face
to face must not be pressed to a literal
event you cannot see the face of god but
god
showed moses an aspect of himself both
no one else had seen for instance in uh
desire of 80's page 761 paragraph five
ellen white writes of lucifer to him as
to no other created being was given a
revelation of god's love and so god
showed lucifer something no other angel
had ever seen a depth of god's love god
showed moses or he allowed him to come
as close as any created being on earth
has ever come but moses did not see the
face of god i have seen god in my life
but i've never seen the face of god
those elders and joshua did not see the
face of god because none of them could
go as close to god as moses could moses
left joshua further down the mountain
with the elders moses and god said only
moses comes so moses saw what none of
the others saw but they saw the evidence
of god's glory they saw what looked like
a sapphire stone under god that's what
they saw they did not see the face of
god the bible does not contain
contradictions the contradictions exist
in our finite minds not in the word of
god and we need to understand that the
eldest and joshua did not see the face
of god
balaam saw an angel it was not the face
of god joshua as he crossed the stream
saw an angel it was not the face of god
even when christ appeared in human form
to abraham in genesis 18 that was not
the full glory of god you cannot see
god's face and live because hebrews 12
29 tells us our god is a consuming fire
he is that right now to everyone who's
cursed by sin so joshua and the elders
did not see the face of god and so what
happened in joshua uh exodus 24 9-11
they saw evidence of god they saw
something that large multitude perhaps
didn't see but they did not even get
close as moses and moses himself did not
see the full face of god god told moses
you'll see my back parts that's what he
told him in chapter 33 uh verse 21 to 22
you'll see my back parts he never saw
god's full face
no one can see that
of course in a new world we'll see him
face to face praise god
in all of his glory in all his glory
amen
elder skeet i'm going to take a question
from last month this is from all right
um she says what does it mean to have
the indwelling of the holy spirit do we
have it or is it or is it something we
obtain or attain
in john let me pray again father as we
continue asking questions or answering
questions give wisdom to me and anyone
else who comments in jesus name i pray
amen
in john 14 16 jesus said this to the
disciples and i will pray the father and
he shall give you another comforter that
he may abide with you forever even the
spirit of truth whom the world cannot
receive because he sees him not and i
don't know with him but he dwelleth with
you and shall be in you the spirit is
given to indwell us i cannot explain the
details of how that happens i only know
jesus said he'll be more than with you
he will be in you
every child of god needs the indwelling
of the spirit of god
when christ walked with the disciples
they had god with them right next to
them when christ left they had to be
infilled with the spirit in his presence
that was all the power they needed let
me say that again in the presence of
christ they were in the presence of god
that was all the power they needed but
when christ left
the spirit representing christ who is
just like christ another comforter he is
the power within that enables god's
people to do what they ought to do that
enables us to resist temptation we must
have the spirit we must be filled with
the spirit if you read the book of acts
you'll see the work of the spirit in the
early church and frequently you read
they were filled with the spirit filled
with the spirit peter was filled with
the spirit acts chapter two stephen was
filled with the spirit acts chapter 7
they were filled with the spirit you and
i must be filled with the spirit that's
how we fill with christ
and by the way
the number one gift we should ask of god
in addition to forgiveness of sins is
the holy spirit let me explain what i
mean
in matthew chapter 7 verse 11 the bible
says if he then being evil know how to
give good gifts unto your children
how much more shall your father which is
in heaven give good things to them that
ask him
matthew says good things luke gives the
same verse and slightly changes the
wording in luke 11 13 he says if he then
being evil know how to give good gifts
unto your children how much more shall
your heavenly father give the holy
spirit to them that ask him matthew says
good things and luke identifies the best
of the lord and that is the spirit of
god we must be filled with the spirit i
read earlier
matthew uh romans 8 verse 9 if any man
hath not the spirit of christ he's none
of his it is the presence of the spirit
within as a directing force a
controlling force with our permission
that marks us as a child of god without
the interning dwelling of the spirit as
a directing force we're not a child of
god we're a church member not a child of
god the spirit must dwell in us as a
directing force what do i mean by that
he guides and directs us through the
word then we are children of god you
must be filled with the spirit
or you'll be filled with another one
[Music]
one or the other fills us
indeed indeed thank you
and i can't recall the exact bible text
but it speaks about the holy spirit
sealing us the sealing of the spirit and
the earnest or the token the sign of
ephesians chapter 4 verse 30. there we
go thank you
visions forever is not the spirit of god
whereby you seal
unto the day of redemption the spirit
the presence of the spirit is a form of
identifying or sealing the very presence
amen amen
jesus was filled with the spirit by the
way
in his humanity he was filled with the
spirit
acts 10 38 how god anointed jesus of
nazareth with the holy ghost and with
power christ in his humanity was filled
with the spirit he was spirit-filled and
we are to be the same way because the
humanity of christ is our humanity
amen amen thank you all the skeet you
know as i'm looking through this
document i'm realizing we have a lot of
questions about the
spirit this is another question from tim
go with holy
haifman
he says is there a difference between
the spirit of god
the spirit of christ and the holy spirit
no
all the same
in romans chapter 8 verse 9 it's an
interesting verse
romans 8 says 8 8
therefore
there are in the flesh cannot please god
nine says but you're not in the flesh if
so be that the spirit of god dwell in
you now if any man have not the spirit
of christ he's none of his so the spirit
is called the spirit of god and the
spirit of christ in the same verse
if you read uh first peter chapter one
from verse 9 receiving the end of your
faith even the salvation of your souls
of which salvation the prophets have
searched and inquired diligently who
prophesied of the grace that should come
unto you now listen to verse 11
searching what or what manner of time
the spirit of christ which was in them
did signify so the bible tells us the
spirit that led the prophets of the old
testament was the spirit of christ but
he's also the spirit of god the holy
spirit is called the spirit of god or
the spirit of christ
amen he represents both perfectly
so when you have the spirit you have the
father and the son
amen amen thank you
so we're now going to transition to some
questions about the sabbath
this one is joyce lino depina
she says as a sabbath keeper does it
make it hypocrites for not working
but yet i guess working on the sabbath
but yet consuming servers provided by
others working on the sabbath like and
she gives this example like going to
church and using electricity provided by
people working on the sabbath
well let's say you go to church that has
no electricity you drive on the streets
that are paved by other people
maintained by other people you know it
you cannot as long as you live on this
earth you cannot avoid interacting with
the things of this earth the only thing
on this earth you should avoid is sin
driving on a road paved by someone else
who did it on the sabbath does not make
you a sabbath keeper because jesus
walked the streets that were prepared by
other people jesus wrote in both that
were built by other people we cannot
avoid life on this earth he free on this
earth we avoid things that are direct
violations of the law of god things that
we can control
so it is not a sin to go worship in a
church that has electricity it is not a
sin at all but if your conscience
bothers you turn the lights off
and shut off the water because the water
is uh arranged by somebody else you know
don't take a shower because your
conscience bothers you on the sabbath no
we cannot avoid interacting with the
world at a certain level we must avoid
the sin of the world
when policemen patrol and keep you from
accidents if you get into an accident on
sabbath the emergency vehicles will come
to you that's not a violation of the
sabbath because christ said it's lawful
to do good if your animal falls in a bit
pull it out so if you get into a crash
and the policeman comes and the fire
department comes that's no sabbath
violation for you
amen because they're doing what they're
supposed to do pulling someone out of
trouble
we must be careful to be as godly as we
can be without going to our
extremes
amen amen the only time we'll get away
from earthly influences is when we're in
the new world or when we're in heaven
i mean this right now we're doing
question and answer
the church where dr indonesia is does
not have his own individual server i
don't believe it is somebody else
providing internet service on the
sabbath what do we do shut it down and
not preach the gospel we must not go to
extremes
please with a capital p please we must
not go to extremes
indeed indeed
all right so i see brother kevin gomez
on that on that topic said not hiring
servants directly on sabbath like going
to a restaurant
now that's a different story that's a
different story you should not be in a
restaurant on sabbath that's a different
story
completely different eat at your own
house or fast or do something but don't
go to restaurant put yourself in an
environment you cannot control so i
agree completed by the gomez
indeed amen amen so friends we have to
be very careful to walk in the middle
not be too lacks and at the same time
not become a fanatic
the christian must also use common sense
common sense is a major part of god's
religion you simply cannot suspend your
common sense and say well the spirit
will talk to me you must use your common
sense now the bible says if thou has run
with the foot men and they have weary
thee how then can't thou contend with
the horses god and say look think i give
your mind if you cannot keep up with a
man how can you keep up with a horse you
have to think if you have an army of ten
thousand men and your opponent has
twenty thousand you better go make peace
because you will lose jesus tells us
that think use your common sense
religion and conversion does not suspend
common sense
indeed indeed
all right well elder skeet i'm looking
here at a question from youtube and
those of you that are watching on
youtube welcome i know you're here from
all over the world i'll call a couple
names sister amyra praise for the
robinson altino and his wife's sister
anna uh evangelist baxter and now we
have a question from
chantal nelson
and i think this was in reference to you
know us seeing or you know seeing god's
face
she asks how about adam and eve did they
see god's face when he visited them
the answer to that is simple isaiah 59
verse one and verse two behold the
lord's hand is not shortened and it
cannot save or his ear heavy that he
cannot hear but your iniquities have
separated between you and your god and
your sins have hid his face from you
that you will not hear sin is the reason
for the separation before adam's then he
could look on god in the new world we
will look on god so the answer is yes
adam and eve in the pure state could
look face to face with god
in the new world revelation 22 verse 4
we shall see his face because verse 3
says there shall be no more curse
and the curse is brought on by sin so
yes adam and eve saw god
spoke this all angels spoke face to face
sin stop them that's why they can only
communicate or we can through the
humanity of christ
that's why we have to get rid of sin as
long as there is sin we are deprived of
the absolute full fellowship with god
and by absolute full i mean not simply
by faith but by actual touching and
seeing with the senses god has given to
us john 14 1-3 let not your heart be
troubled you believe in god believe also
in me in my father's house are many
mansions if it were not so i would have
told you i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come again and receive you unto
myself what does he mean by that through
faith we are with jesus christ but not
at the level he desires because christ
is still physical even though he's god
and so he's in the most holy place we
are on this earth so there's still a
separation between us and god
christ wants the ideal which is face to
face man or emmanuel as they say and
that will only come when we lose the
sinful nature and the new world is made
then we can see god as adam saw him
amen amen thank you elder skeet so we
see the thing that separates us from god
is sin so adam and eve in their pure
state without sin we're able to yes of
course the faith of god
now i see someone here on zoom has their
hand raised slk i will unmute you and
allow you to ask your question
yes we can hear you thank you
thank you versus feet and sister nisha
for the opportunity to ask a question
i'm shane by the way
um my question relates to first john
chapter 3 and verse 6 obviously it says
whoever abides in him does not sin that
sins has neither seen him nor known him
so i understand the first part but
that's just that we ever since have
never seen him nor known him that i've
been struggling to understand so i was
just wondering if you could elaborate on
that faster thanks all right
whoever sinneth have not seen god not
unknown him the sea there does not mean
see with your eyes it means to perceive
and understand who god is and when it
says whosoever sinneth have not seen god
it means practice sin not just makes a
mistake you know you know john jesus
told nicodemus in john chapter 3 verse 3
except the man be born again he cannot
see the kingdom he cannot conceive of it
he cannot perceive it it's not an
optical seeing it is seen by grasping
with the mind and so the bible says
someone who practices sin does not
understand who god is in that sense he
does not see god and the holiness of god
and the sinlessness of god under
tremendously high standard god has for
us which is his character and so to not
see god is to not understand who god is
you know sometimes people say oh i see
they do not mean i see optically they
simply mean i understand someone
constantly practicing sin has not seen
who god really is it has nothing to do
with the eyes
amen amen okay that's okay i hope that
your question was answered and i'm sorry
you mentioned your name before and i
have already forgotten but thank you
skeet for that response
so we're gonna go on with some other
questions i know we had some questions
about the sabbath
this one comes from ash horn haywood
he says i am from the caribbean country
of saint vincent and the grenadine
and i just want to call out sister
beverly redisford who's on faithfully
with us who is the president of the st
vincent american adventist association
okay so he says i am
from the country of saint vincent and
the grenadines
and i'm a seven-day adventist my
question is if you have a job and you
have to work on the sabbath and you
don't want to work but you have to go
and while on the job your mind is on the
sabbath and worshiping god in your mind
how will god feel is that considered
breaking the sabbath because someone
can't go to church
yes it's breaking the sounds now to read
the first part again of that question dr
denisha read the first part there's
something interesting the person says
read the first part
okay so you go and while on the job no
no reach from the very beginning from
the very okay
my name is ash rory hayyard from the
caribbean country of saint vincent and
the grenadines i am a seventh-day
adventist
my question is if you have a job uh-huh
you have to work on the sabbath you
don't have to work on the sabbath that's
the point i'm trying to make no one can
force you to break the commandment you
have chosen to go there's no such thing
as you have to go
the only thing you have to do is die if
christ doesn't come you do not have to
work on the sabbath daniel did not have
to bow to that image of the three hebrew
boys daniel did not have to pray to
darius he chose the lions then the three
hebrew boys did not have to bow to that
image they chose the fiery furnace god
chose to deliver them you do not have to
work on sabbath so that is flawed god
bless whoever the person is but you do
not if you go you have willfully
disobeyed god how can that please god
don't tell god well how will i eat he'll
find a way for you to eat as he found
for the israelites in the wilderness how
will i take care of my children god
rewards obedience first samuel chapter 2
verse 30 them that honor me i will honor
i don't mean to sound harsh but i want
to be plain you do not have to work on
sabbath as a matter of fact you can
choose to die rather than disobey and
i'm not joking you can choose to die
rather than disobey god
indeed death before dishonor death
before dishonor there's no such thing i
have to go because i have bills no
you ought to say i have to obey because
i love god
amen amen
i don't want to let me just say my good
doctor nation
sometimes i come across as very harsh
i'm not really harsh but i want to make
sure when i answer the question you're
not confused what i'm saying is you do
not have to go to work on sabbath that's
all i'm saying but god bless you god
bless you and save you
amen amen
next question
all right this question comes from
shawnee leah
she says my name is shawnee leah from
nairobi kenya
amen i have a question for pastor randy
what is the biblical significance of
selling one's birthright like what esau
did
he saw in genesis 29 he sold his
birthright for a bowl of let's call it
lentil soup he did not appreciate the
value of spiritual things let's just
simplify this thing he placed the
commonplace the material above the
spiritual this must never happen in the
life of the believer the birthright
involved the coming of the messiah
through that person it involved all the
privileges of leading the families the
high priest a double portion of the
father's inheritance the birthright was
everything to a jewish young man
esau disregarded spiritual things he
disregarded the things of god
simply for one ball of cottage in other
words he set spiritual things aside just
to survive for one day his crime was in
devaluing disregarding spiritual things
for the sake of temporal
common things
and he despised it
and of course we know what happened to
esau esau is not named in the 12 tribes
he saw well of course they were the
children of jacob but esau is not an
example of spiritual power he despised
his birthright there are some believers
who despise the bible because they
convict them some of us despise the
council of ellen white we despise the
health message we despise the
educational philosophy we despise
decency as the bible defines it we
despise anything that interferes with
our sinful lives
esau despised a spiritual gift
and that was his crime
and you and i must value the spiritual
above the the secular we must do that
when the disciples brought physical food
to christ and physical food has its
place don't misunderstand me god made
fruit trees and we must eat them the
tree of the life is physical but jesus
said in john 4 i think verse 31 32 i
have made to eat you no not off job said
i have esteemed the words of his mouth
more than by necessary for it jeremiah
said thy words were found i beneath them
this is the point to which we must come
that the spiritual means more to us than
the physical or the secular or the
carnal
esau refers that
that made it criminally spiritually
criminal behavior
a lot of church members value the world
above spiritual things notice that
they're church members not children of
god a child of god values spiritual
first but a lot of church members value
the secular over the spiritual
but a child of god will reverse that
will value the spiritual above the
secular
always
amen amen it's about priorities who'd we
want to be
first
in our lives
all right elder skeet i have this
question from a 19 year old seventh-day
adventist named audrey mutuca mutocoma
and she says i've been battling with
this question for a year now
can adventists date or marry
non-adventist no well no don't just say
yes you can
because cain could kill abel and he
killed him adam could eat the fruit and
he could devour the fruit eve could and
she did yes you can but biblically
you're wrong with a capital w let me say
it again you are wrong
being on and equally yoked together with
unbelievers simple as that adventist
homepage 67 paragraph one to unite with
an unbeliever is to place yourself on
satan's ground you grieve the spirit of
god and forfeit his protection the
simple answer is yes you're wrong
let me back up and be nice
let me try to be nice
i don't know why
don't do let's go to genesis chapter six
we'll read the first one but let me pray
again father help me to be soft in my
responses their god so that your people
will understand i care about them i
really want them to follow thus said the
lord now give me the words i pray in
jesus name amen listen to genesis 6 from
verse 1 and it came to pass when men
began to multiply on the face of the
earth and daughters were born unto them
that the sons of god saw the daughters
of men that they were fair and they took
them wives of all which they chose and
the lord said my spirit shall not always
strive with man for that he also is
flesh yet his day shall be 120 years
mixed marriages is the only clearly
identified sin of the anti-delusion
world let me say it again mixed
marriages is the only clearly identified
the bible says the world was filled with
violence genesis 6 verses 11 and 12. we
know that yeah and then 13 but the one
identified by name that led to the
condition of the world was mixed
marriages
when the israelites were coming out of
egypt going into the canaan land god
told the israelites very clearly do not
make marriages with the unbelievers
don't even have business arrangements
with them
so well whoever asked the question if
you're in such a relationship break it
off right now
send a text
send an email
break it off right now the best time to
do what's right is now
and god bless the 19 year old but
whether you're 19 or 1999 the same thing
applies don't do it
amen amen
may we do what is right
now
when you do what's wrong repent simple
as that
indeed indeed but other skeet we'll take
one last question i'll take this
from avery jones actually no avery
um
he says what do i say to someone who
asked me how do i know that god exists
what if everything does occur at random
and things formed at random as the big
bang theory professes
the knowledge of god is a very personal
thing
in uh i think it's jeremiah 29 13 and he
shall seek me and find me when he shall
search for me with all your heart
discovering god is a personal experience
i cannot prove to someone else that god
exists i can prove that for me
and i can have concrete evidence in my
life that there's a god but i cannot
prove to you that god exists the bible
does not try to prove that god exists
the bible simply states in the beginning
god created it does not waste time
trying to prove anything and so we
cannot prove to someone else god exists
we can tell the person you go searching
for god and he will reveal himself to
you and god will do that let me say it
again god will reward anyone who
sincerely searches for him and so i say
again the search for god must be a
personal search but i cannot prove i can
bring all the fancy arguments about
design or whatever else but only in the
personal life can we conclusively prove
that there is a god
i mean conclusively
trying to prove god existed jack and
jill and johnny and joseph will be
fruitless
but i know as i sit in this chair
i have proven for myself
that there is someone called god and no
amount of encyclopedic arguments can
ever change my mind from the fact there
is a god because i have seen him in my
life but i cannot prove that to you but
i can tell you go do what i did and
search for him because god yearns to be
discovered that's the thing you know dr
denisha you're in a scientific
environment people get millions of
dollars to fund this research and that
research and there's no results god's
research guarantees results with no
funding you go search for god and he
will give you results without spending a
penny come search for me says god i'll
reveal myself to you but i cannot prove
to you that god exists
i can tell you what he's done for me and
what he's done for me he's willing to do
for you because god wants to be known
you see if god is not known how can he
be worshipped god wants to be worshipped
he must be known
amen amen you see it all comes back as
he said elder skeet to that personal
relationship with god and getting to
know him intimately
and indeed there are some things that we
cannot prove with the most philosophical
arguments that's right and and you know
as you said looking at design and
looking at the rocks and this is that
but the life
transformed it's one of the greatest
testimonies that we have that indeed god
is real
there's evidence that god exists outside
the world but the proof he exists is in
personal experience with him let me say
that again you may say this is evidence
that god exists
i have proof that he exists and the
proof is in what he has done in my life
amen
well elder skeeter someone put in the
chat the time has slipped by so fast can
you yes it has it is already one hour
yes yes and i have another segment soon
after this
yes so elder skeet i'm going to bring
things to a close right now all right
okay those of you that have questions in
the chat we will mark them and put them
on our open forum question those of you
on youtube brother akeem charles good to
see you sister regina wetterburn angela
buckbear mally booth sister spencer i
see you're on
all of you thank you so much for joining
this q a session elder randy skeet to
you we express great thanks
for going at lengths to be here on this
live i note that you are not home i'm no
no i'm in tennessee i came to do some
recordings for gospel ministries
international i came last friday i'm
leaving tomorrow and so that's where
i've been i'm not home very good you're
very perceptive i'm not home no
yes elder skeets we say thank you for
taking the time out of that mission work
there for gospel frontline uh to be here
with us on this live may the lord bless
you and your wife the entire family
richly supplies all your needs and as
you always tell me may god bless you
abundantly now i have friends all over
the world but whenever i hear there's
someone from the west indies on i'm
always excited so that person from
vincent may the lord bless you anyone
else connecting from the west indies god
bless wherever you are there was someone
from kenya i have tremendously close
friends from kenya god bless you and if
you're from any other country where i
have connections thank you very much and
god bless you let me say again dr anisha
i may come across as hard and harsh i am
not
i simply want to make sure that when i
answer your question you know exactly
what i said you don't have to wonder
what did he say what did he say i said
yes i said no i said black or i said
white that's all that's going on when
you see me looking like this that is all
that is going on and god bless all of
you who put your questions to me
amen amen thank you all the skeet we
know that you are a nice man yes yes yes
especially on several so god because god
is good
amen amen we express many thanks to you
eldest people
father
and brother lawrence of wood thank you
so much for
asking the questions i know the internet
wasn't quite in our favor a bit but god
pulled through and you were able to ask
three questions so we thank god for your
willingness we know it is well now after
eight o'clock where you are in ghana so
thank you very much for being on this
live stream and may god continue to
bless you and your ministry happy
sabbath family so friends feel free to
check out brother lawrence it was a
youtube channel happy sabbath family for
short clips
uh discussing the lesson study about
five minutes or so discussing the lesson
for the entire week so you don't want to
miss that
um brother
well let me not say brother but sister
queen sister queen myers thank you so
much in advance for doing the closing
prayer and i would just like to invite
all of you to join us by god's grace and
let me share my screen
there we go feel free to join us by
god's grace sabbath march 26
for a q a with elder well excuse me with
profess
stationary work and the three angels
messages will be joined by brother
jonathan david archie brother kevin
gomez and brother gideon bristol who is
also from ghana um he will also be on
the program so feel free to keep this
ministry in prayer and tune in by god's
grace march 26th i'm at two o'clock
q a with professor walter fight on
medical missionary work and the three
angels and messages
now we will be blessed by a meditation
piece by brother
courtney fadlin he has submitted
a recording
and i pray that we are blessed by this
peace as we seek to climb up that ladder
of salvation he has given us the song
still i rise
[Music]
[Applause]
man
[Music]
oh
ah
[Music]
yes
me
[Music]
um
hey
[Music]
bye
hey
[Music]
amen amen i just want to read because i
know this was an instrumental
the passage of scripture where this song
was sourced from this is second
corinthians chapter four
verses eight through ten it says we are
troubled on every side
yet not distressed we are perplexed
but not in despair persecuted but not
forgotten cast down but not destroyed
always bearing about in the body the
dying of the lord jesus that the life
also of jesus might be made manifest in
our body today friends as we seek to be
sanctified as we pursue sanctification
may we ever press on and arise climbing
up that ladder of salvation through the
power of jesus christ and the indwelling
of the holy spirit i will now allow
sister queen myers to do our closing
prayer thank you
happy sabbath everyone
may we bow our heads in prayer
dear heavenly father
thank you for loving us thank you for
being the almighty
i pray that as your children you we
dedicate our lives to you i pray that
our services are dedicated to you as we
serve our brothers and sisters
please father answer all our requests
according to your will i pray that you
watch over your you
guide us in the time of need we are weak
and you are our only source of strength
we can do anything in christ who
strengthens us help us through school
work exercise hood heal us mentally
strengthen us physically and emotionally
we are dear father in need of your
sanctifying grace may your may you take
our worries and fears away father
forgive us forever doubting you in any
way
may obedience be our priority provide
for us any opportunity to learn more of
you
i pray that you bless everyone's heart
dear lord deliver us from the evil one
and guide us to walk in your path
pardon our sins
set our campus heart captive hearts free
and the mighty name of jesus christ i
pray amen
amen amen
thank you so much sister queen and to
those of you that are on zoom thank you
facebook youtube twitter twitch may the
lord bless you all thank you for your
presence and god willing we'll meet
again
god willing march sabbath march 26th i'm
at 2 o'clock p.m eastern standard time
for q a with professor walter fight on
medical missionary work and the three
angels messages and perhaps you'll see
us later on this afternoon as we do some
train ministries so may the lord bless
you and keep you and cause his face to
shine upon you and give you peace thank
you all and god bless